these Illusions pop off the pavement
into the real world and are created by
this man form a NASA illustrator turned
3D artist Kurt winter what illusion does
fundamentally it tells us or reminds us
that everything we think is real is in
some way an illusion
the geometry of the Illusions is very
precise and they are made to be seen
from exactly one point in space
here was a work where I designed the
central figure of Bacchus The Works
called the wine Fountain peace is
enormous every one of these squares is
quite large as well you can see by the
people sitting on the work
mapping this precise visual geometry
begins with diligent planning using
pencil and paper so here's an example of
how I start a picture here I start with
the grid
and then on top of the grid I start to
compose using What's called the
thumbnail sketch thumbnail sketch
because one of these horses heads is
literally the size of my thumbnail the
information from each one of these
squares is going to then be turned back
into a real Square meaning x equals y
and so what we see here is that when
we're toward my viewpoint this is very
much like a normal square root I have to
distort it very little this Square I
have to distort more this one I'll have
to distort more insulin and so on until
I have to really blow this Square out to
get it back into a square starting from
the thumbnail I then work my way up to a
more finished line drawing and then what
happens here is I scan and print the
little detail on another piece of paper
which looks a lot rougher
and then I I refine the detail on this
and then I cut them together this whole
composition here needs to be blown out
in the sense that I have to take each
one of these perspective curvilinear
squares and turn it back into a square
square and when I do that the
composition ends up looking like this
work would
take complete
but Kirk can demonstrate his creative
process on a smaller scale
[Music]
foreign
this is freehand drawing and there would
almost never in any case be a trace on
the pavement the kind of chalk I'm
drawing with is a commercial chalk that
you can buy whereas the other chalks you
see in these different containers are
handmade pastels I do make them myself
nobody makes a pastel where the content
pigment content is 100 I just wanted the
colors to be stronger and blend less so
my pastels are made with pure pigments
which means they're the powdered color
the oxides are the chemicals that make
the color are the entire content of The
Pastels whereas when you buy a pastel or
a chalk it's about 30 percent of the
content traditionally you know of course
every image is its own thing but an
optimal size is about 15 feet by 15 feet
and that's the size where you get the
most Bang from your box so from the
point of view of a person standing at
the base of the drawing and says taking
a photo which has become the reality at
least of this work that the image fits
just about the right amount of the
camera frame compared to the environment
around the image and other Spectators
people on misunderstand the impermanence
people think you do the work and then it
goes away
but when you're dealing with with
materials and situations where the work
is impermanent doesn't work that way the
work is going away while you're doing it
so it's like building a sand castle
where you get you know a little tower on
the left side and you go build a toe on
the right side and the left one has
fallen down
this is the best possible office anybody
could have when it's this beautiful day
when the temperature is nice nothing
better than this office but it can also
be an office where it's rainy it's cold
it's windy or noisy or unbelievably hot
when I did this piece during an event
the pavement was so hot that it was
literally burning the materials I was
working with
regardless of the challenges Kurt brings
his pieces to life sometimes in a
jaw-dropping scale this was the world
record size pavement art 440 feet long
one of the interesting geometrical parts
of this work is that the bottom part of
the work was done on the ground at full
size so while the bottom of the painting
where the people are standing was
painted on the pavement itself on this
it's actually an airstrip the part above
where this panoramic part was painted on
a curved panel much smaller which was
suspended from scaffolding so the shot
is a camera shooting through this curved
panel which is cut out here and then
seeing the enormous pavement art
underneath with all the people standing
on it most of whom were the artists that
helped execute this work
Kurt's art has always been a consuming
passion fascinated by how he can plant
the extraordinary in the midst of every
day
how much time have I spent in life
thinking about this I think I've spent
my entire life thinking about this
starting from when I was eight years old
I'm 64 years old so that puts me at well
over half a century that I've been
thinking about these problems is this
similar to how you model your pieces
yeah that's exactly how I model my
pieces especially before when I was
doing them before we had photography and
Photoshop and all of that a drawing is
in scale which means that these grid
lines here each are one inch by one inch
they correspond to one foot by one foot
in real life this little model here is
about five and a half inches tall as is
this one and then this would tell me
that a person standing with an eye level
of five and a half feet standing here in
a person five and a half feet standing
at the back end of an eight foot by ten
foot image this will appear in a certain
way with a lens which is at this
particular distance which we fixed and
this particular height and is centered
on the pavement surface
and the iPhone then is going to tell me
in the viewfinder what a person would
see now the first thing to do though is
to get the focal point in the right
place so I do this by having these two
little towers and I can move the two
towers up to these lines and position
exactly where my lens is going to be so
you have to let the camera tell you
where its focal point is by looking at
the image through the lens you're going
to be using eventually somebody would be
drawing or composing in this area but
there's a number of examples of things
they can use in order to see the effect
so at this point this effect of this
person standing on the sphere
so here's the image in the correct
position and then if I take it and move
it this way of course the illusion is
going to fold up it almost appears like
a paper pop-up book where the the whole
thing folds down and becomes flat this
way it wouldn't be illusionistic it's
only going to be an illusion when it's
exactly in the right position
this ability to bend reality with
geometry started when Kurt was a young
man with some parental encouragement
my father saw that I was interested in
art he was a mathematician and scientist
so he gave me this little paperback book
called The geometry of Art and life and
this little book described how geometry
is used both in art and by nature and so
that book fascinated me
[Music]
I had worked for NASA before and had
developed certain ways of doing
perspectives to capture very very wide
angle views of things especially planets
and spacecraft when I left my job and
started working on the streets of Rome
as a pavement artist I started by doing
classical Works after a while I wanted
to do my own original works and I
started to also notice that the works on
the pavement were seen always from the
base of the work which means people were
looking as much across the surface the
work as they were looking down at the
work so I decided I could use some of
the technology or the techniques that
I've used at Nasa on the street
calculating the actual position of the
viewer and making the work accurate from
that position rather than composing the
work as if it were a wall painting it
was a little bit strange because the
first piece where I looked at and I said
oh this is a new art form this never
existed before was the dscra piece
I didn't do a drawing for this piece I
actually composed it on the street
painstakingly stretching out all of the
different figures using geometry and
considering each figure separately later
on I figured more of an overall
geometrical formula which allows me to
design the works on paper in scale and
then enlarge them this piece took me
about six weeks to design and finish and
then in this case the design and the
Finish was on the same spot because I
didn't have preliminary drawings from it
do you do this art for you or for the
public that is such a profound question
is this art for me or for the public
that's a question that could actually be
applied to all art in some way I think
artists are always expecting that
they're communicating with other people
this is an art form which grew up as a
communication tool it grew up as a way
to engage the public the beauty of the
work is to consider the environment The
Spectators the public the point of view
of the viewer and to compose a work
which creates a relationship between all
those three elements
[Music]